et nous verrons
pour
only à maraka heures
ce sont quand même des gens qui sont
capables de passer d'un extrême à
l'autre d'une présidence à l'autre ils
ont clinton il est lisse georges de
bellio bouche le contraire après il
passe à obama le contraire exact il
repassa tram c'est plus que le contraire
donc on voit bien qu'il ya une sorte de
malaise profond
le malaise américain et celui d'une
puissance devenue impuissante
donald trump en est le symptôme excessif
il voudrait restaurer l'aura de
l'amérique d'hier et pense que cela sera
plus facile en s'isolant en masquant ses
faiblesses pour éviter d'essuyer des
échecs comme celui de l'irak qui chaque
jours fragilise un peu plus l'amérique
devenu colosse aux pieds d'argile
[Musique]
retrait d'irak éloignement de l'europe
incapacité à écrire une politique
vis-à-vis de la russie les etats unis
sont en réalité déstabilisé depuis la
fin de la guerre froide il ya un quart
de siècle qui prend avec le recul les
allures d'une victoire à la pyrrhus
barack obama a esquissé une solution la
politique du pivot en se tournant vers
l'asie
mais là encore rien n'est simple les
américains doivent désormais affronter
l'ambition chinoise sur la région dans
un environnement déstabilisé par la
nucléarisation de la corée du nord
en se tournant vers l'asie l'amérique
découvre que sa puissance est devenu une
puissance relative elle se retrouve face
à la chine qui ont tant avoir un rôle
politique à la mesure de sa puissance
économique
mais surtout dans ce face à face les
américains sont obligés de se trouver
des alliés en cas de conflit sino
américain alors barack obama s'est à
nouveau rapproché de l'allié japonais en
[Musique]
la politique est aussi une histoire de
symboles et barack obama l'a bien
compris lorsqu'ils décident de se
tourner vers l'asie en soutenant à
nouveau le japon il offre un nom qui
reste celui du rêve américain
la nomination par barack obama de
caroline kennedy la fille du président
assassiné comme ambassadrice au japon
est un des signes très forts de la
volonté d'obama de pivoter vers l'asie
commune l'a répété maintes fois durant
sa présidence et le fait qu'ils
choisissent cette personnalité et
qu'elle incarne ce mythe de cette
famille royale américaines quand elles
arrivent au japon elle représente
vraiment ce que l'américain de meilleur
évidemment les japonais ont très bien
réagi d'ailleurs elle a été accueillie
de manière
inouïe
puisqu'elle a eu le droit ou défilé en
carrosse dans les rues de tokyo jusqu'au
palais impérial pour porter sa lettre de
créance
obama a rappelé à plusieurs reprises les
états unis soutiendraient le japon en
cas de conflit avec qui que ce soit dans
la région et ont notamment la chine
s'était pas tout à fait ce que laissait
entendre donald trump en tant que
candidat à la présidence des états unis
puisqu'il avait dit aux japonais au
coréen vous vous débrouillerez prendrait
en charge nous on s'occupera pas de tout
ça
[Musique]
le premier ministre japonais shinzo abe
a convaincu donald trump de poursuivre
la ligne politique définie par barack
obama donald trump va effectivement se
résoudre à privilégier le japon mais
avec une maladresse incroyable
en juillet 2017 et l'envoi des tweets où
il pourfend le soutien de pékin à kimi
angolais en remettant la corée du nord
au centre des relations internationales
donald trump tombent dans le piège
coréen et fragilise l'amérique car si
pyongyang multiplie les provocations
militaires c'est pour traiter avec les
états unis et retrouver une place sur la
scène internationale
la corée du sud a accepté contre la
volonté chinoise d'installer sur son
territoire un système antimissile
américain ce qui a valu aux chinois he
de mettre en place des sanctions assez
forte contre les sud-coréens les chinois
sont très très très très très embêté et
ils sont embêtés pas seulement parce qu'
ils hésitent mais sont embêtés parce que
ils ont des difficultés à prendre des
décisions dans leur pays il faut
imaginer que les provinces qui borde la
corée du nord en chine sont des
provinces qui sont très puissantes là où
il ya beaucoup de détachement militaire
et on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi
avec ces provinces qui elle-même profite
de tous les trafics avec la corée du
nord mais la chine ne veut pas non plus
d'une réunification
qui ferait que l'ensemble de l'accord et
serez unifié sous l'égide de la corée du
sud avec l'alliance americana in envol à
aucun prix aucun prix les chinois eux ne
veulent absolument pas et ça c'est quoi
qu'il arrive ils ne veulent pas d'avoir
deux soldats américains à leurs
frontières parce que c'est ça le
principal risque pour eux c'est de se
retrouver avec des soldats américains à
leurs frontières
l'amérique de trump est donc une
américain puissante
impuissante au proche orient impuissante
en asie et il a été élu pour re donner
l'illusion de la puissance